the now rose festival is first and  foremost a new year celebration but it's  also a beloved and honored source of  cultural pride for the predominantly  Kurdish people's of dia Kabir in  southeast Turkey representatives of a  Kurdish political party read a special  announcement to the gathered throngs  jailed leader Abdullah Ocalan has  advised members of his militant PKK  party to call a special Congress the  convention will mark the beginning of a  new era we will enter a phase of  peaceful coexistence with the Republic  of Turkey our took we will live with the  democratic identity and as a democratic  society with constitutional freedom and  equality the crowd was overjoyed at the  message richland has been in prison for  over a decade and turkey has banned his  PKK party the struggle for Kurdish  autonomy has caused tens of thousands of  lives over recent decades now he says  it's time to terminate what he called  this brutal and disastrous history